Oil sands operations contribute significant carbon emissions in Canada. So the six largest companies have teamed up to make strides on the path to NetZero. Investing in technology and innovation. Already cut emissions in average 22% per barrel. Working with governments to create and protect jobs. Developing one of the world's largest carbon capture and storage facilities. Our NetZero plan is in motion and we're making progress on multiple pathways. See our plan in action at pathwaysalliance.ca
加拿大油砂运营产生了大量的碳排放。因此，六家最大的公司联手在迈向净零排放的道路上取得进展。投资于技术和创新。平均每桶碳排放量已经减少了22%。与政府合作创造和保护就业机会。开发世界上最大规模的碳捕集与封存设施之一。我们的净零计划正在实施中，我们正通过多种途径取得进展。请访问 pathwaysalliance.ca 查看我们的行动计划。
Music In the early 80s, a series of savage attacks occurred in the Twin City area of Minnesota, USA. The victims were all women. Police struggled in the initial part of the investigation. There was no physical evidence left by the attacker and there were no witnesses. But there was one person who wanted to help the police. The man responsible. He called 911 after committing the attacks.
音乐 在20世纪80年代初，美国明尼苏达州双城地区发生了一系列残忍的袭击事件。受害者全都是女性。警方在调查初期遇到了很大困难。袭击者没有留下任何物证，也没有目击者。但有一个人想要协助警方。那就是肇事者本人。他在作案后拨打了911。
The tapes were released to the public in the hopes that somebody would recognize the voice. This is how he came to be known as the Weepy Voice Killer. But was he just taunting the police? Or did he really want to be stopped? Music On the 31st of December 1980, University student Karen Potak was out celebrating New Year's Eve with her sisters on University Avenue. In an area known as the Twin Cities in Minnesota, USA.
这些录音被公之于众，希望有人能认出这个声音。这就是他被称为“哭泣的声音杀手”的由来。但他只是在挑衅警方？还是他真的希望被阻止？音乐 1980年12月31日，大学生凯伦·波塔克（Karen Potak）和她的姐妹们在大学大道（University Avenue）上庆祝新年夜。地点位于美国明尼苏达州被称为双城的地区。
The city of St. Paul, which is the state capital of Minnesota, is on one side of University Avenue. And the city of Minneapolis, which is the largest city in Minnesota, is on the other side of University Avenue. Music It was a nice cold winter's night, with temperatures below freezing. After midnight had struck, Karen wondered out of the bar she was in with her sisters. She walked around the streets in the freezing cold, all alone, still drinking from a glass of champagne. She made her way up an alleyway, which was deserted other than one car which drove past her. A male driver was the only person in the car.
圣保罗市是明尼苏达州的首府，位于大学大道的一侧。而明尼苏达州最大的城市明尼阿波利斯市则位于大学大道的另一侧。音乐 那是一个寒冷的冬夜，气温低于冰点。过了午夜之后，凯伦独自离开了她和姐妹们所在的酒吧。她在严寒中独自漫步在街头，手里还端着一杯香槟。她走进了一条小巷，除了有一辆车从她身边开过之外空无一人。车里只有一名男司机。
She noticed that Karen didn't have a jacket, and she looked freezing cold. The male driver stopped the car and told Karen to jump in. He had the heater on, and his car was nice and warm, and he could give her a ride to wherever she needed to go. The lure of a nice warm car and a free ride was too much for Karen to resist, and she eagerly jumped in. At about 3 a.m. that morning, the following call was made to 9-1-1. Please, this is an emergency. Please send a squad to Kirsten Lurell, Malmberg Manufacturing Company, Machineshop. Please, there's an ambulance too. There's a girl who's there. Can you tell me what happened to her?
她注意到凯伦没有穿夹克，而且看上去冻得瑟瑟发抖。男司机停下车，叫凯伦上车。他开着暖气，车里非常暖和，他可以载她去她想去的任何地方。温暖舒适的车和免费搭车的诱惑让凯伦无法抗拒，她急切地跳上了车。当天凌晨3点左右，有人拨打了以下911求救电话。求求你们，这是紧急情况。请派一辆警车到马尔伯格制造公司的机械车间，基尔斯滕·鲁雷尔。请派一辆救护车来。那里有一个女孩。你能告诉我她怎么了吗？
There's three of her. She's laying on the ground in the back by the little jack, by the edge of the city. What's the address? I don't know. Police responded to the call and found Karen Potak lying on the ground near the railway tracks behind the Malmberg Manufacturing Company on Syndicate Street, North St. Paul, an area that was completely deserted at night. Karen was naked and had been viciously beaten with a tire iron. Her skull was cracked open, but she was alive. Karen was rushed to hospital and treated. She survived the attack, but it was so vicious, it was deemed to be an attempted murder.
她有三个人。她躺在城市边缘小千斤顶后面的地上。地址是什么？我不知道。警方接警后赶到现场，在北圣保罗辛迪加街的马尔伯格制造公司背后的铁路轨道附近发现了躺在地上的凯伦·波塔克，这里夜间人迹罕至。凯伦赤身裸体，曾遭到轮胎撬棍的残酷殴打。她的头骨破裂，但她还活着。凯伦被紧急送往医院接受治疗。她从袭击中幸存下来，但由于手段极其凶残，该案被判定为谋杀未遂。
Karen was later questioned at length by police, but she had no memory of the attack itself, and no memory of who was responsible. No physical evidence was located to identify the attacker, and there were no witnesses at all. With Karen unable to provide police with any information, the case went cold very quickly, and nobody was arrested. 18-year-old Kimberly Compton was from the small town of Peppin, Wisconsin, with a population of less than 1,000 people. After graduating from high school, Kimberly packed her bags and got on a bus headed for Minnesota's capital city, St. Paul. Like so many other small town high school graduates before and after her, she couldn't wait to leave and start the next chapter of her life in the city. On the 3rd of June 1981, Kimberly stepped off her Greyhound bus in downtown St. Paul. She hired locker number 750 in the Greyhound bus depot, where she placed both of her bags.
此后，警方对凯伦进行了长时间的盘问，但她对袭击本身毫无记忆，也不记得凶手是谁。现场没有找到任何可以确定凶手身份的物证，也完全没有目击者。由于凯伦无法向警方提供任何线索，案件很快陷入僵局，无人被捕。18岁的金伯利·康普顿（Kimberly Compton）来自威斯康星州小镇佩平，人口不到1,000人。高中毕业后，金伯利收拾好行囊，登上了一辆开往明尼苏达州首府圣保罗的巴士。和她前后无数个小镇高中毕业生一样，她迫不及待地想要离开，去城市开启人生的下一个篇章。1981年6月3日，金伯利在圣保罗市中心走下了灰狗巴士。她在灰狗巴士总站租了750号储物柜，把两个包都放了进去。
The first thing Kimberly wanted to do was to eat. She was starving, and she was in luck. Directly across the road from the bus depot was Mickey's diner. They had a special on two, barbecue, beef and fries, and that's what Kimberly ordered. She sat down in a booth to eat, and sitting a few booths away from her was a man also enjoying a meal. He noticed Kimberly sitting alone, and he walked over and struck up a conversation with her. Kimberly told him she'd only just arrived to the city and didn't know her way around yet. The man was only too happy to offer to drive Kimberly around and show her the sights of St. Paul.
金伯利的第一件事就是想吃东西。她饿极了，而且她很幸运。巴士总站马路对面就是米奇餐厅（Mickey's diner）。他们当天推出特色菜：两份烤牛肉配薯条，这就是金伯利点的食物。她在一个卡座坐下来吃饭，离她几个卡座远的地方坐着一个同样在享受美食的男人。他注意到金伯利独自一人，便走过去和她搭话。金伯利告诉他，她刚来到这座城市，还对这里不熟。这名男子非常乐意提出开车带金伯利四处转转，带她看看圣保罗的风景。
Kimberly eagerly accepted. She couldn't wait to explore the city, and was happy that she had a local to help show her around. Kimberly and her new friend finished their meals, and then left Mickey's diner together. A few hours later, the following call was made to Norm on one. Hello? Are you there? Police responded and found Kimberly Compton laying face down, near an unfinished freeway just south of St. Paul. There was a secluded area where you could catch a nice view of the Mississippi River. The killer had driven Kimberly there, and then used the promise of that nice view to lure Kimberly out of the car. She was then savagely attacked.
金伯利欣然接受。她迫不及待地想要探索这座城市，也很高兴能有一个当地人带着她四处看看。金伯利和她的新朋友吃完饭，一起离开了米奇餐厅。几个小时后，有人向诺姆拨打了求救电话。喂？你在吗？警方赶到现场，在圣保罗南郊一个尚未完工的高速公路附近发现了面朝下倒在血泊中的金伯利·康普顿。那是一个可以欣赏密西西比河美景的幽静地方。凶手把金伯利带到那里，然后用欣赏美景的借口把金伯利诱下了车。随后她遭到了残忍的袭击。
Kimberly was stabbed 61 times with a nice pick, and was dead when police arrived. Kimberly couldn't wait to graduate high school and leave the small town of Peppin behind her. But only hours after leaving and arriving in St. Paul, she had been brutally murdered. Kimberly had no identification on her, but police found her great-hand bus depot locker key. They found her locker and her bags, and that's how the initial identification was done. The autopsy showed an undigested meal in her stomach, which is how police were able to piece together the movements. They knew that Mickey's diner was across the road from the bus depot, and when they saw the special they had that night that Kimberly arrived in town, match what was in her stomach, they were able to piece the movements together.
金伯利被冰锥刺中了61次，警方赶到时已经死亡。金伯利迫不及待地想高中毕业，离开佩平这个小镇。但在离开并到达圣保罗仅仅几小时后，她就被残酷杀害了。金伯利身上没有携带任何身份证件，但警方找到了她灰狗巴士总站储物柜的钥匙。他们找到了她的储物柜和行李，初期的身份确认就是这样完成的。验尸结果显示她胃里有未消化的食物，警方正是通过这一点拼凑出了她的行踪。他们知道米奇餐厅在巴士总站马路对面，当他们发现当晚他们提供的特色菜与金伯利胃里的食物吻合时，他们便得以还原了她的行踪。
They immediately interviewed the staff of Mickey's diner and appealed for anybody who may have seen Kimberly to come forward. But they couldn't find any witnesses that progressed the investigation any further. There were no suspects, no physical evidence. The investigation stalled. But not before the killer made another call to 911. Police released the 911 call to the media. It was hoped that somebody would recognize the voice. The media nicknamed him the Weepy Voiced Killer. The response was overwhelming. Everybody seemed to think the voice matched somebody that they knew. Over a hundred names were provided to the police, but unfortunately it all amounted to nothing.
他们立即走访了米奇餐厅的员工，并呼吁任何见过金伯利的人站出来提供线索。但他们没能找到任何能推动调查进展的目击者。没有嫌疑人，也没有物证。调查陷入了停滞。但在凶手再次拨打911之前并非如此。警方将911录音公之于众。希望有人能认出这个声音。媒体给他起了个绰号叫“哭泣的声音杀手”。社会反响十分强烈。每个人似乎都觉得这个声音和他们认识的某个人很像。警方收到了上百个名字，但遗憾的是最终都一无所获。
The release of the calls got them no closer to identifying a suspect. And with no evidence and no witnesses, the case started getting colder and colder. About nine months after the murder, on March 19, 1982, there was this news report from KSTP Eyewitness News. The police thought they may have had a breakthrough. Locally tonight, St. Paul police are disappointed. They thought they were close to solving one of the city's murders, but new information has sent the police back to square one in the murder case of Kimberly Compton. That information came to light when police took a rare step and opened their files to the media. Lindsay Strand has more on the story.
公布录音并没有让他们更接近锁定嫌疑人。在没有证据和目击者的情况下，案件变得越来越扑朔迷离。谋杀案发生大约九个月后的1982年3月19日，KSTP目击者新闻播报了这样一条新闻。警方认为他们可能取得了突破。今晚本地消息，圣保罗警方感到失望。他们本以为自己快要破获该市的一起谋杀案了，但新线索却让警方在金伯利·康普顿谋杀案上回到了原点。这些线索是在警方采取罕见举措向媒体公开档案时浮出水面的。林德斯·斯特兰德（Lindsay Strand）将为您带来详细报道。
Retired St. Paul detective Earl Mills returned to the force for one day this week to open the files of his seven-month investigation to the media. He said he was convinced information received four days after he retired last February answered the question of who killed Kimberly Compton. Mills believed it was Alan Lopez indicted for killing his parents and sister at their St. Paul home last August. Found mentally incompetent to stand trial, Lopez was sent to the state security hospital in St. Peter, where he committed suicide before police could talk to him. But while barricaded inside his family's house last summer, he had confessed to killing Compton. Police, however, had ruled him out as a suspect because they linked the Compton murder to another case they didn't believe Lopez could have committed. The link was in tape telephone calls to police.
退休圣保罗警探厄尔·米尔斯（Earl Mills）本周重返警队一天，向媒体公开了他历时七个月的调查档案。他说，他坚信去年2月退休四天后收到的线索解答了是谁杀害了金伯利·康普顿的问题。米尔斯认为凶手是艾伦·洛佩兹（Alan Lopez），他因去年8月在圣保罗家中杀害父母和妹妹而被起诉。洛佩兹被判定精神失常无法接受审判，随后被送往圣彼得州立精神病院，并在警方找他谈话前自杀身亡。但在去年夏天在其家人住所内与警方对峙期间，他曾供认杀害了康普顿。然而，警方此前已将他排除在嫌疑人之外，因为他们将康普顿谋杀案与另一起他们认为洛佩兹不可能犯下的案件联系在了一起。这一联系是通过打给警方的录音电话建立的。
Kimberly Compton's body was discovered last June along an unfinished portion of 35e, only three and a half hours after she arrived in town by bus. The report then plays the 911 voice recordings relating to Kimberly Compton's murder. They then link the case to the attempted murder of Karen Potak and play that 911 recording. The news report then continues. Arriving at the location the caller described, police found Karen Potak badly beaten but still alive. Police didn't think Lopez could have committed the attack because they thought he was in the Inoka state hospital that night. But just five weeks ago, Mills learned that Lopez was granted a pass to leave the hospital the day Potak was assaulted. And that information made him confident Lopez attacked both women.
金伯利·康普顿的尸体是去年6月在35e高速公路未完工路段旁被发现的，当时她乘大巴抵达该镇仅三个半小时。报道随后播放了与金伯利·康普顿谋杀案相关的911语音录音。随后，他们将该案与凯伦·波塔克的谋杀未遂案联系起来，并播放了那段911录音。新闻报道随后继续。到达报警人描述的地点后，警方发现凯伦·波塔克遭到严重殴打，但依然活着。警方原以为洛佩兹不可能实施这起袭击，因为他们认为当晚他在伊诺卡州立医院。但就在五周前，米尔斯得知洛佩兹在波塔克遇袭当天获准离开医院。这一消息使他确信洛佩兹袭击了这两名女性。
Based on the telephone calls we received his vicious nature with his family. The fact that he was not in an institution, public institution at the time of either of the cases. But information obtained by the media and the new investigator on the case has shattered Mills' theory. One phone call to the Ramsey County Jail determined that while Lopez may have been out of the state hospital the night that Potak was attacked, he was in the Ramsey County Jail the night Kimberly Compton was murdered, clearly ruling him out as a suspect in the case and sending police back to square one in their investigation. Police Chief William McCutcheon refused to comment directly on the quality of the investigation, but said that quality of future investigations should be improved by a recent departmental reorganization.
基于我们接到的电话、他对家人的残忍本性。他在两起案件发生时都不在公共机构内。然而，媒体和本案的新调查员获取的信息粉碎了米尔斯的理论。拉姆齐县监狱的一通电话确认，尽管在波塔克遇袭当晚洛佩兹可能确实离开了州立医院，但在金伯利·康普顿被谋杀的那天晚上，他正身处拉姆齐县监狱，这明确排除了他是本案嫌疑人的可能，并使警方的调查回到了原点。警察局长威廉·麦卡切恩（William McCutcheon）拒绝直接对调查质量进行评论，但表示最近的部门重组应该会提高未来调查的质量。
Lindsay Strand, Channel 5 Eyewitness News, St. Paul. And square one of the investigation is exactly where police remained. As the months went on new cases came in and Kimberly's case got less and less attention before it was eventually placed on the cold case shelf where it was barely touched. On the 6th of August 1982, 40 year old Barbara Simons was having a night out at the Hexagon Bar in Minneapolis. Barbara was having fun up on the dance floor dancing and drinking with a man she had just met that night. At one point when she was ordering a drink she mentioned to the waitress that she hoped the man she had met was a nice guy because he was going to give her a ride home.
林德斯·斯特兰德，5台目击者新闻，圣保罗。而调查的原点正是警方停滞不前的地方。随着时间的推移，新案件不断涌现，金伯利一案受到的关注越来越少，直到最终被束之高阁，几乎无人问津。1982年8月6日，40岁的芭芭拉·西蒙斯（Barbara Simons）在明尼阿波利斯的六角酒吧（Hexagon Bar）度过了一个夜晚。芭芭拉在舞池里玩得很开心，和她当晚刚认识的一个男人一起跳舞喝酒。有一次她在点酒时，向女服务员提起她希望自己刚认识的这个男人是个好人，因为他要开车送她回家。
Later that night the waitress saw them leaving the bar together and then another phone call was made to 911. Please don't talk to the waitress. I'm sorry I killed my girl. I've stabbed her 40 times. Kimberly talked to her the first time I've seen her. Oh my God, I don't want to die this way. I'm going to kill myself and thank you. Where are you? I still want to die this way. She asked me I can't go this way. I'm going to make it this way. Police later located the body of Barbara Simons caught on the underbrush down an embankment of the Mississippi River in Minneapolis.
那天晚些时候，女服务员看到他们一起离开了酒吧，接着又有人拨打了911。请不要跟女服务员说话。对不起，我杀了我的女孩。我刺了她40次。金伯利跟我说话是我第一次见到她。哦，天哪，我不想这样死。我要自杀，谢谢你。你在哪？我还是不想这样死。她问我，我不能这样走。我要这样走。警方随后在明尼阿波利斯密西西比河堤岸的下层灌木丛中找到了芭芭拉·西蒙斯的尸体。
The killer had tried to dispose of her body in the river but the underbrush stopped that from happening. Barbara had been stabbed around 100 times. It was evident there was now a serial killer at work. Police traced Barbara's movements on the night of her death and that eventually led them back to the hexagon bar into an interview with the waitress who saw her dancing with an unknown man. The New Brunswick, always inviting. Visit tourismnewbrunswick.ca Police showed the waitress several mug books in the hopes she would be able to identify the man she saw Barbara with. The waitress looked through over 100 photos before the police were in luck.
凶手曾试图将她的尸体抛入河中，但下层灌木丛阻止了这一情况的发生。芭芭拉被刺了大约100刀。很显然，当时有一个连环杀手在作案。警方顺藤摸瓜，追踪了芭芭拉遇害当晚的行踪，最终将他们带回了六角酒吧，并采访了那位看到她与一个陌生男子跳舞的女服务员。新不伦瑞克省，总让人心驰神往。访问 tourismnewbrunswick.ca 警方给女服务员看了几本嫌疑人照片册，希望能认出她看到和芭芭拉在一起的那个男人。女服务员翻阅了100多张照片，随后警方终于时来运转。
She picked out the man she saw with Barbara. This was a huge break in the investigation. Police immediately organized for a surveillance team to closely follow their new suspect. Soon after on the 20th of August 1982, 19 year old prostitute Denise Williams was working in the Red Light District of Minneapolis. Denise had been a prostitute since she was 13 years old. A car pulled up to Denise. The male driver started chatting to her and they came to an agreement. The male offered her $100 to have some fun. But he only had $40 on him at the time. He promised to buy her the other 60 later. Denise agreed and got into his car and they went back to his apartment in St. Paul where they had sex.
她认出了她看到和芭芭拉在一起的那个男人。这是调查工作的一个重大突破。警方立即组织了一支监视小组，密切追踪他们的新嫌疑人。不久之后，即1982年8月20日，19岁的妓女杰尼斯·威廉姆斯（Denise Williams）在明尼阿波利斯的红灯区工作。杰尼斯从13岁起就开始从事性工作。一辆车停在了杰尼斯旁边。男司机开始跟她聊天，两人达成了协议。男子提出给她100美元来寻开心。但他当时身上只有40美元。他承诺稍后会把剩下的60美元补给她。杰尼斯同意了，上了他的车，两人回到了他在圣保罗的公寓并发生了性关系。
It was over very quickly and Denise started wondering if the man was going to want more. But he didn't and he offered to drive Denise back to her corner. On the way back to the Red Light District, the man veered off the main road and started taking some back streets. The man said he was taking a shortcut. But Denise started to get uneasy. She knew the area and knew this wasn't a shortcut. She started to look around for a weapon and was in luck when she spotted a bottle close by. Denise decided that if the man tried anything, she would whack him in the head with a bottle. The man pulled into a dark dead end parking lot near Coolidge Avenue in Minneapolis. There was no street lighting at all. When they stopped, the man said to Denise, ass, grass or gas. No one rides for free.
过程结束得非常快，杰尼斯开始琢磨这个男人是不是还想要更多。但他没有，并主动提出开车送杰尼斯回她原来的街角。在返回红灯区的路上，这名男子突然拐离主路，驶入了一些小巷。男子说他是在走捷径。但杰尼斯开始感到不安。她熟悉这一带，知道这不是什么捷径。她开始四处寻找武器，幸运的是她发现附近有一个瓶子。杰尼斯决定，如果这男人敢图谋不轨，她就用瓶子砸他的头。男子将车开进了明尼阿波利斯库利奇大道附近一个黑暗的死胡同停车场。这里完全没有路灯。车停下后，男子对杰尼斯说：要么给钱，要么给草，要么给油。天下没有免费的搭乘。
Denise tried to get out of the car but the man grabbed her left arm and then stabbed her in the stomach with a screwdriver. Denise reacted by hitting him in the head with a glass bottle, closing it to smash. She hit him a few more times with a broken bottle. He started bleeding everywhere. He was cut up pretty bad on the cheek, head and hand. But that didn't stop him. He kept trying to stab Denise over and over again. She reacted by trying to punch, kick and bite him. She fought as fiercely as she could. Denise eventually managed to open the door and fell out onto the ground. The male fell on top of her. Denise decided to change tactics and she stopped fighting altogether. She played dead. She said, on dying, on dying, and laid completely still. But that didn't work. The man kept stabbing her.
杰尼斯试图下车，但男子抓住她的左臂，随后用螺丝刀刺向她的腹部。杰尼斯的回应是用玻璃瓶砸他的头，导致瓶子碎裂。她用破酒瓶又砸了他几下。他开始到处流血。他的脸颊、头部和手部都受了很严重的伤。但这并没有阻止他。他 계속 试图一遍又一遍地刺杀杰尼斯。她的反应是试图用拳打、脚踢和咬来反击。她拼尽全力进行反抗。杰尼斯最终设法打开车门，跌落到地上。男子压在了她身上。杰尼斯决定改变战术，她完全停止了反抗。她假装死了。她喊着，我要死了，我要死了，一动不动地躺着。但这不管用。男子继续刺杀她。
Denise screamed for help and a nearby resident, Douglas, panning, heard her screams. He made his way outside and saw the attacker on top of Denise, still stabbing her. Panning ran up and grabbed him. The attacker jumped up and then immediately swung the screwdriver at Panning. Panning ran away but the attacker gave chase. Luckily Panning was able to make his way back inside his unit and call the police. The attacker gave up, jumped back into his car and drove off. He was badly cut up and injured. Panning went back outside to help Denise. Denise had been stabbed 15 times. She had wounds on her chest, abdomen and head, as well as a punctured lung and a punctured liver. She was rushed to hospital where she had emergency surgery. Despite being badly hurt, Denise survived the attack. Denise initially gave her name as Mary, as she was aware there was a warrant out for her arrest for a probation violation. She also told the police she had been hitchhiking when she was attacked. But Denise later came clean and told the truth.
杰尼斯大声呼救，附近的一位居民道格拉斯·潘宁（Douglas Panning）听到了她的尖叫声。他走到室外，看到袭击者正压在杰尼斯身上，还在不停地刺她。潘宁跑过去抓住了他。袭击者猛地跳起来，立刻挥舞螺丝刀向潘宁刺去。潘宁逃跑了，但袭击者紧追不舍。幸运的是，潘宁设法逃回了自己的房间并报了警。袭击者放弃了追赶，跳回车里开车逃走了。他浑身是伤，伤势严重。潘宁再次走到室外去帮助杰尼斯。杰尼斯被刺了15刀。她的胸部、腹部和头部都有伤口，肺部和肝脏也被刺穿。她被紧急送往医院接受了紧急手术。尽管伤势严重，杰尼斯还是从袭击中活了下来。杰尼斯最初自名为玛丽，因为她知道自己因违反缓刑规定而有一张逮捕令。她还告诉警方自己在遇袭时正在搭便车。但杰尼斯后来坦白并说出了实情。
That same night, shortly after the attack on Denise, another call was made to no one but one. Paramedics were dispatched to the address. Police were called as well. There they found 37 year old Paul Stefani. The man picked out in the mug book by the waitress at the hexagon bar. The man who police had a surveillance operation on. But earlier that night, just before making his way to the red light district, Stefani had lost the police tail, leaving him free to attack Denise Williams. Luckily, she survived. Stefani was arrested and Denise easily picked him out as her attacker from the mug shots. Stefani was charged with her attempted murder. Paul Stefani was born on the 8th of September 1944 and grew up in Austin, Minnesota. He was brought up in a deeply religious household. He had a history of psychiatric problems and one previous conviction for aggravated assault, which is why his photo was in the mug book.
就在当晚，在对杰尼斯的袭击发生后不久，又有人拨打了一个求救电话。急救人员被派往该地址。警方也赶到了现场。他们在那里发现了37岁的保罗·斯蒂凡尼（Paul Stefani）。这个男人就是六角酒吧的女服务员从照片册里认出的那个人。也就是警方一直在监视的那个男人。但在当晚早些时候，就在前往红灯区之前，斯蒂凡尼甩掉了警方的追踪，这让他得以伺机袭击杰尼斯·威廉姆斯。幸运的是，她活了下来。斯蒂凡尼被捕，杰尼斯一眼就在嫌疑人照片中认出了他就是袭击自己的人。斯蒂凡尼被指控谋杀未遂。保罗·斯蒂凡尼于1944年9月8日出生，在明尼苏达州奥斯汀长大。他在一个笃信宗教的家庭中长大。他有精神病史，并有一项严重攻击罪的前科，这就是为什么他的照片会出现在照片册中。
He worked as a janitor and lived by himself. In March 1977, Stefani was fired from his job at the Malmberg Manufacturing Clean. So he was familiar with the area where Karen Potack was attacked and was well aware how quiet and isolated the spot would be at nine. Police interviewed him about the attack on Karen Potack and the murders of Kimberly Compton and Barbara Sawments. They showed him crime scene photos from all three attacks. Stefani looked at them and said, you're not going to pin those on me. He denied any involvement in the crimes and denied being the weepy voice killer. Along with the attempted murder of Denise Williams, Stefani was charged with the murder of Barbara Sawments.
他是一名门卫，独自居住。1977年3月，斯蒂凡尼被马尔伯格清洁公司解雇。因此，他对凯伦·波塔克遇袭的地点非常熟悉，并且很清楚那个地方在九点时有多么安静和偏僻。警方就凯伦·波塔克遇袭案以及金伯利·康普顿和芭芭拉·索门茨的谋杀案对他进行了讯问。他们向他展示了这三起袭击案的犯罪现场照片。斯蒂凡尼看了看，说道：“你们别想把这些罪名扣在我头上。”他否认参与这些犯罪，也否认自己是那个哭泣的声音杀手。除了涉嫌谋杀未遂杰尼斯·威廉姆斯外，斯蒂凡尼还被指控谋杀芭芭拉·索门茨。
These attacks occurred in Minneapolis, a different jurisdiction to the attacks on Karen Potack and Kimberly Compton. Those happened in St. Paul. Stefani plead not guilty to the murder of Barbara Sawments and the six-week trial commenced in February 1985. The prosecution case relied on matching the 911 calls made after Barbara Sawments' attack and after Denise Williams' attack to the voice of Stefani. An audio interview conducted with Stefani shortly after his arrest was used to try and make the match. The experts that were called in concluded that the voice of Stefani was remarkably similar to the 911 calls, but they could not conclusively say they were an exact match. That's when Stefani's sister was called to the standard testifier.
这些袭击发生在明尼阿波利斯，与凯伦·波塔克和金伯利·康普顿遇袭案属于不同的司法管辖区。后者发生在圣保罗。斯蒂凡尼对谋杀芭芭拉·索门茨的指控做出了无罪抗辩，为期六周的审判于1985年2月开始。控方的证据主要依赖于将芭芭拉·索门茨遇袭后以及杰尼斯·威廉姆斯遇袭后拨打的911电话与斯蒂凡尼的声音进行比对。在斯蒂凡尼被捕后不久对其实施的一段音频采访被用来尝试进行匹配。受邀前来的专家得出结论，斯蒂凡尼的声音与911录音惊人地相似，但他们无法明确断言它们完全一致。就在这时，斯蒂凡尼的妹妹被传唤出庭作证。
She listened to the 911 tapes, she then bowed her head and said that she had no doubt those calls were made by her brother. After a six-week trial, Stefani was eventually found guilty and sentenced to 40 years in jail for the murder of Sawments. Stefani also plead not guilty to the attempted murder of Denise Williams. That also went to trial, but he was eventually convicted and sentenced to 18 years in jail. So with these results, you're now thinking that prosecutors in the jurisdiction of St. Paul would jump on board and get to work charging Stefani for the attempted murder of Karen Potak and the murder of Kimberly Compton. Well, you're wrong. Prosecutors stated the voice evidence was not enough and they were unable to pursue a conviction against Stefani for those attacks. Instead, they elected to label them officially unsolved, giving Karen and the family of Kimberly no closure.
她听了911录音，随后低下头说，她毫不怀疑这些电话是她哥哥打的。经过为期六周的审判，斯蒂凡尼最终被判有罪，因谋杀索门茨被判处40年监禁。斯蒂凡尼对谋杀杰尼斯·威廉姆斯的未遂指控也做出了无罪抗辩。该案也进入了审判程序，但他最终被定罪并被判处18年监禁。看到这些结果，你现在可能会认为圣保罗司法管辖区的检察官会立即行动起来，起诉斯蒂凡尼谋杀凯伦·波塔克未遂以及谋杀金伯利·康普顿。好吧，你猜错了。检察官表示，声音证据不足，他们无法针对这些袭击对斯蒂凡尼提起定罪诉讼。相反，他们选择将这些案件正式列为未破悬案，这让凯伦和金伯利家属的悲剧永远无法真正画上句号。
In 1997, 12 years later, Stefani got in contact with the St. Paul police. He had just been diagnosed with terminal cancer and he wanted to talk to somebody and clear the slate. St. Paul police went and met up with Stefani and conducted an interview with him. He confessed to the attempted murder of Karen Potak. She ran my car and I gave her my drive until I said that he would be out on the middle of the drive and clean some of the ice off the windshield. Do you remember where you hit her with the tire? We did. I mean, did you hit her one time, two times?
1997年，也就是12年后，斯蒂凡尼与圣保罗警方取得了联系。他刚刚被诊断出患有晚期癌症，他想找人聊聊，坦白一切。圣保罗警方前往并与斯蒂凡尼见面，对他进行了讯问。他供认了对凯伦·波塔克的谋杀未遂。她截住了我的车，我让她上了我的车，直到我说他应该走到车中间去清理挡风玻璃上的一些冰。你还记得你用轮胎撬棍打她哪里了吗？我们打了。我是说，你打她一下，还是两下？
Nothing, about 30 times, but I mean, I would poke 20 times when I go down. Were you swinging it this way or did you poke her with it? I don't think I poked her. I remember just hitting her on the forehead, on the cheek, on the jaw, on the mouth, on the top of her head. I think it was only about 10 times. I mean, I know you must really be rid of that, you know, a few of our, like that. I was even rid of it. When I went back to Trump, oh, there's no like this.
没，大概打了30下，但我的意思是，当我倒下去的时候我可能戳了20下。你当时是这么挥着打的，还是用它戳她？我觉得我没有戳她。我只记得打她的前额、脸颊、下巴、嘴巴、头顶。我觉得大概只有10次吧。我的意思是，我知道你一定真的很想摆脱那个，你知道的，我们当中的一些人，就像那样。我甚至想摆脱它。当我回到特鲁姆普时，哦，没有这样的。
I mean, that's what I mean. Maybe you want to go to the phone. I mean, I really wanted to help her. I said, my mind started tearing up. What are you doing? You have a chance to make another friend like that, you know what I'm saying? You like to make friends. And to the murder of Kimberly Compton.
我的意思是，这就是我的意思。也许你想打电话。我的意思是，我真的很想帮她。我说，我的脑子开始流泪了。你在干什么？你还有机会再交这样一个朋友，你知道我在说什么吗？你喜欢交朋友。以及谋杀金伯利·康普顿。
And then I would just start telling me where she was from. And I was bouncing and all that. And I said, hey, why don't you, I'm not even thinking about who's going to write it. I was like, hey, how much longer do you want me to show you downtown? I said, yeah, I want to show you something. There's really a nice view over here and you can see the major building. I think I met some of you. You probably have something to tell your friends about them.
然后我就会开始告诉我她来自哪里。我在那里跳来跳去什么的。我说，嘿，你为什么不，我甚至没去想谁会写下来。我就像，嘿，你想让我带你在市中心逛多久？我说，对了，我想让你看点东西。这里真的风景很好，你能看到那栋大楼。我想我见过你们中的一些人。你可能有些事情可以跟你的朋友们讲讲。
Because I walked out of the car and I carried my mate with me. I had every intention to hurt him. We'll lay down in the grass and then we'll open up a garage. A garage. And then I'll just kill an a** up. I mean, it's first time though. Detectives got a shock when Stefani confessed to another murder that he wasn't even on the radar for. 33-year-old Kathleen Greening was drowned in a bathtub at her home on the 21st of July, 1982.
因为我走出了车，随身带了我的工具。我当时存心想伤害她。我们将躺在草地上，然后我们会打开一个车库。一个车库。然后我就会把事情搞砸。我的意思是，不过这是第一次。侦探们大吃一惊，因为斯蒂凡尼还坦白了另一起他们甚至闻所未闻的谋杀案。33岁的凯瑟琳·格林宁（Kathleen Greening）于1982年7月21日在她家中的浴缸里被溺死。
Only a few weeks before the murder of Barbara Sorens. You say that you both get into the tub? Yes. And you should. You're positive about that? Yes. Because I mean, I remember when I pushed her head under water, I just see her face. Did you push her in there?
就在谋杀芭芭拉·索伦斯的几周前。你是说你们俩都进了浴缸？是的。你是说你们俩都进去了？你确定吗？是的。因为我的意思是，我记得当我把她的头按进水里时，我只看到了她的脸。你把她推到里面去了吗？
Did you push her head down or did you push her chest area under the water or did you help her shoulder down? You help her shoulder down? Yes. Both hands in? Detectives found the cold case file for Kathleen Greening's murder. Going through the file, they found an address book belonging to her that had been taken as evidence. In the book was a name Paul S. with a telephone number. They matched that telephone number to the one Stefani gave the night he was arrested for Denise Williams' attack.
你是把她的头部往下按，还是把她的胸部区域按到水里，或者你帮着把她的肩膀往下按？你帮着把她的肩膀往下按？是的。两只手都用上了？侦探们找到了凯瑟琳·格林宁谋杀案的未破悬案档案。翻阅档案时，他们发现了一本属于她的通讯录，该通讯录曾被作为证据收缴。本子上有个名字叫保尔·S（Paul S.），并附有一个电话号码。他们将该电话号码与斯蒂凡尼因袭击杰尼斯·威廉姆斯而被捕当晚提供的电话号码进行对比，发现两者完全吻合。
It never came out what their relation was prior to the attack or why his number was in her address book. But finally, justice had been done for Karen Potack, Kimberly Compton and now Kathleen Greening. The prosecutor who secured the conviction for the murder of Barbara Simons doesn't believe Stefani enjoyed or relished in committing murder. He felt guilty for what he had done and wanted to be stopped. That's why he made the nine-month long calls. But he couldn't stop himself. And when he was eventually caught, he couldn't even admit to what he had done. In Stefani's words, killing seemed to be the thing you were supposed to do that was part of life.
袭击发生前他们是什么关系，或者为什么她的电话号码会出现在他的通讯录里，这些细节从未公之于德。但最终，正义终于降临到了凯伦·波塔克、金伯利·康普顿以及如今的凯瑟琳·格林宁身上。负责获取芭芭拉·西蒙斯谋杀案定罪的检察官认为，斯蒂凡尼并不享受或迷恋杀人过程。他为自己的所作所为感到内疚，并希望被阻止。这就是他连续九个月拨打电话的原因。但他无法控制自己。当他最终被捕时，他甚至无法承认自己所做的一切。用斯蒂凡尼的话说，杀人似乎成了你本该去做的事情，那是生活的一部分。
Until he actually did it. That's why I can't give another one. You can't be in Stefani or you can't be in Stefani. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
直到他真正做了这件事。这就是为什么我不能再给别人一个。你不能在斯蒂凡尼，或者你不能在斯蒂凡尼。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。